he's none other than general manager of
the Arizona Cardinals Steve Tom how are
you Steve
don't gray rich and you still are
gracing our draft board but man is
exhausting as an NFL draft it is I can
only imagine what it is to host it and
as usual you've done you've done a
fantastic job and really enjoyed the
coverage
Daniel Jeremiah who was a good friend of
mine I always had a lot of respect for
him I thought he did a fantastic job as
well well I appreciate that Steve and
you certainly kept things interesting
for me and everybody else I'll tell you
that he kept it interesting all right
let's let's get into it here so many of
my colleagues call it the worst kept
secret that you were taking Kyler Mari I
mean when did you finally make that
choice or has it really been hand barn
for a while no I mean I really has not
because you know number of people
thought that it was at the combine when
we really started to discuss it which is
not not the fact I mean it was really I
didn't even watch him until after the
combine I was very reluctant to to
evaluate the player because I was scared
I was going to fall in love with him I
big Josh frozen fan for a number of
reasons and so it was a difficult
decision but in the end
calimary to me was too hard to pass up
just because of the skill set he
possesses one what's that skill set that
was too hard for you to pass up Steve
well just in you know in the years that
I've been doing this a guy that can run
unlike him and can throw it like him I
mean I've seen him you know michael vick
can run 'like him and and guys that i've
seen like russell wilson who can throw
like him but not not the combination not
the guy who can extend plays with his
feet and can make the throws with
accuracy and timing in touch and what
about the grease board stuff that we
heard about from my colleague charlie
Casserly was there any concern on that
front did you put him on a grease board
Stephen yeah we did we did we spent a
lot of time with him and not only did he
do a great job of that I mean the the
easiest transition is the fact that the
offense that he ran in Oklahoma is very
similar to what cliff runs so you know
Lincoln Riley and cliff know each other
well and the time that we spent with the
Oklahoma staff and and with the Tyler on
the board I mean we didn't have any
concerns so then what was the issue
about maybe
taking him wad you what why did it take
so long for the hay to get in the barn
well you know I think that you know all
along everybody said that cliff was in
love with Tyler and that sort of thing
and there's no doubt that cliff was a
big fan but I really respected the the
process where cliff didn't pound the
table and say we have to have this guy I
wanted to be organic I wanted to be able
to go through the evaluation process
here what our scouts had to say here
what our coaches had to say and
obviously I had to give him a stamp of
approval and then ultimately at the end
your friend mr. bit allowed to give us
his blessing right yeah and so what was
that meeting like it was great I mean
Michaels extremely supportive you know
he spent a lot of time with Tyler as
well and I think that he saw the number
of things that we saw in Tyler to get
excited about and there's no doubt in my
opinion that you never should say now
it's the State Farm Stadium it is going
to be electric this fall Steve time
general manager the Cardinals joining me
here and there are some who believe your
work with calamari has not yet done
because of that sport called baseball
where does baseball stand in all of this
Steve well like I said prior to the
draft any general manager that was
considering and taking him would have to
do their due diligence and we certainly
did ours and I'm very confident that
that's not going to be an issue
is there gonna be something codified in
the contract about it yes okay is that
language worked out as you and I are
having language with each other right
now
yes okay that's done your your that that
the the the I guess language hay is in
the barn to keep using that phrase right
now yeah and then again you know just
the time that we spent with him and and
how passionate he is about football and
and you know his commitment to the game
I mean I think that we all felt very
comfortable too so you know you always
have to have checks and balances and sir
everything worked out for us so the idea
that if if he does play football and he
does get his figurative you-know-what
handed to him because of his size
stature this is again this is the
conversation that's had football I mean
the number of people that have whispered
this in my ear or shouted it to me in
text I've lost track that that if he
does not succeed in this regard and says
you know what
go to the Oakland A's he could not do
that without some sort of financial
penalty yeah yeah I don't want to get
into the particulars but there will
there's always going to be some
protection built into contracts like
that all right Steve time general
manager the Cardinals here on the
Richardson show is it true you did not
talk about trading rosin until you
already had calamari in the fold is that
a fact that is not correct I actually
had conversations all the way back to
the combine even though we didn't know
who we were going to select people
approached me now what I did not do is I
did not actively shop Josh Rosen I you
know had a number of teams talk to me
about him
told them I'm hoping minded make me an
offer so that's the way I approached it
obviously conversations as we approached
the draft increased and at the end of
the day the best deal that we felt like
for us was Miami Dolphins do you think
that if you had decided we're going to
take Maurice a back when people thought
that you did around the combine that it
would have been better off for you to
have made a rosin trade then Steve I
don't I don't and you know I think that
you know bottom line is is people had an
opportunity to make me an offer and the
other fact is is I was I was content
keeping both of them and I know that's
hard for some people to believe but I
also limped into a playoffs with our
third string quarterback a number of
years ago to me you can't have enough
good players in one position
yeah depth is certainly something that
general managers are responsible for and
Josh Rosen's a darn good football player
no there's no doubt and then obviously
the finance is involving Josh right now
or something that made him just as
attractive to the Dolphins as he was to
you we assume in the draft last year as
well so my question for you is is there
anything you regret about the handling
of Josh Rosen Steve we love Josh I mean
there's no doubt about it and it's not
about Josh in my opinion it's more about
Carla Murray and the unique skillset
that he brings to the table on how he'll
direct our offense
I think josh is gonna be a great
quarterback from Miami and I think he'll
do good things down there I mean I
really enjoyed my time while he was here
the conversations we had and the one
thing about him that sort of jumped out
at me last year his mental physical
toughness is off the charts
I don't know what the perception was
about him coming out of UCLA but he is
he is one tough hombre well why does he
have that perception still Steve I mean
you're hearing it even as he goes out
the door with you with a a very high
class video that he tweeted out were
even had some fun with his lodging that
could be available for Kyler to Terrell
I mean what what what is it about Josh
do you think Steven no I'm not sure I
mean III thought last year he did a
great job of dispelling any questions
about him during the season but you know
I know this he did a great job for us so
there's certainly nothing that I can
point to that would be a question
question all right a few more left with
Steve calm Cardinals general manager if
somebody come up to you after you trade
it up for rosin last year and say you're
gonna trade them next year what would
you said and I'd be hard to understand
any circumstances other than the one
that just happened that would happen you
know and I I know it sounds far-fetched
but you know again if I didn't get the
field that I got while watching the tape
of calimary and how dynamic he is
there's probably it it is probably zero
chance of that happening alright and and
we're all assuming what this offense is
going to look like give us an idea of
how it all fits together with your
pieces like David Johnson and a goat
like Fitz that you have there Steve how
does this all get put together for you
well the biggest thing we had to do is
address his sad playmakers to help Tyler
and and to me you know that's one of the
things we did in this draft and drafting
three receivers who were ranked one six
and eight statistically you know in
terms of production and NCAA receiving
with Andy Isabella who's a speed guy
Akeem Butler and Keyshawn Johnson the
other Keyshawn Johnson yes but you know
I think that those guys are are all
playmakers they all come in different
shapes and sizes you know Butler's a big
long
that's what a guy Isabella's on the
smaller side explosive and then Keyshawn
Johnson to me was one of the better not
natural route runners in this draft so
all playmakers who have a chance to help
this offense and there's no doubt that
David Johnson and Fitz and Tyler will
benefit from help and if I told you back
when you started being a regional Scout
way back in the day in the late 90s
Steve that you'd be a general manager
drafting a five foot ten and one eighth
inch quarterback number one overall your
response would have been what no you're
crazy there's no doubt about it
I mean we have certainly evolved as a as
a league as an organization and and you
know I think that's the one fun thing
about it is really now you have a chance
to see that everybody's got an
opportunity and again it goes back to do
you have you know the skill set to to
offset that and when you say he's short
he's five foot ten he only has five
balls batted down versus other guys in
this draft particularly a six foot five
quarterback and won the first round who
had twelve balls batted down his ability
to escape the pocket to slide and fight
windows is uncanny
which is why to me he was the clear
selection for us okay and when it's all
said and done Steve did you go into this
process thinking you could get a one for
Josh Rosen did you uh you know I didn't
I didn't know what we would get I'd I
certainly that's not the way I operate I
it was wishful thinking for sure but you
always want to be open minded and and
weigh in what's the worst-case scenario
what's the best-case scenario and that's
the way we approached it and like I said
earlier we would have been just as happy
to keep him as well this may be a silly
question but I gotta ask it calamari
week one starter against the Lions
Steve yes you did not stutter no we
didn't have to one overall him to ride
the pine so I know it's a lot to put on
his back but you know that's why we
draft him he's a fierce competitor and
that's what he did at Oklahoma sere he
put the team on his back they didn't
have a great defense and he knew he had
to score almost every series to give
them a chance to win and I sort of like
the chances there all right Steve
thanks for the call really appreciate it
thanks for the con words about the NFL
Network draft coverage - always great my
man we're going to keep you
my board for years to come you know what
Steve as long as I'm running as long as
I'm out there running and and you choose
the the proper photograph I'm all fine
I'm all fine thanks my friend always
good to talk to you thank you Steve
that's appreciated Steve Conte general
manager for more of the Rich Eisen show
tune - audience Channel 239 on DirecTV
for free on BR Live or download the Rich
Eisen show app